my texting buddy paul wall just said uh
i just want everybody to know my t-shirt
said burn it
not bernie i i was gonna i was gonna be
like oh you're a big bernie sanders fan
to bring it up but
you know we ended the conference and i
didn't want to get political with him
either you know there's nothing worse
when someone goes
yeah nothing's worse than people talking
politics over zoom either
with three yeah white rapper and then
let's do dumbasses talking about
politics
yeah that's not why we had paul while on
here yeah that's i'm kind of excited for
his new album though
me too subculture he said boy don't miss
dude
slappers all the way around yeah he got
dude he got flow for days dude so i got
my grill right it's the bottom
did i i sent you a picture nick of my
son wearing it yeah it it didn't really
lock in
so my son was obsessed with it so he
wore it all day he was on a scooter
right in the room
damn i know i was like damn slow down
daddy
slow down dude
really yeah you believe it young fella
got that little grill on them
no yeah i sent to you right nick no
yeah it's not going up weird in them i
wish the tie i wish i would have got the
top they only sent the bottom
the other thing is they did the mold a
year ago at the comedy you might have
grown
i i think i was getting my teeth a
little more crooked maybe and then also
i was
real nervous i don't know what the other
comic see me get my grill put up did it
fast
i did it fast and behind a car what yeah
it looked like a very sketchy
translation
and the guy was like damn chill bro i
was like just get it done
oh god damn i felt like you're losing
your virginity
in high school i was nervous bill burr
would see me or rogan
yeah what are you doing over there
getting molds from my grill
yeah yeah have some pride in it yeah
have some pride in that
paul wall was with me let's see where
the grill started
we let's look at the the origins of it
yeah yeah who's the first
well i know a long time look at that
what's the song he really likes he likes
the baby oh yeah he likes the baby
yeah the baby's got grills artists
a long time ago when they used to have
slaves and and servants and stuff
they would put jewelry in some of them's
mouths too i really make them wear
more valuable yeah just be like this is
my
guy you know have you seen what drake's
doing these days he has a lot of
celebrities doing they just have one
diamond oh yeah one two three yeah
that's cool
you should get that done yeah i think we
should do it we should we should do it
just that one diamond hitter right there
that'd be sick wait drake does that
charge it to king in the sting houston
or memphis they got
is popular for grills right there yeah
someone sent me a picture with uh
because i got it and then the dude who
sent to me he's he he [ __ ] with paul
wall and his guy
he's he's like a tulidge under them and
he's like everybody rock them so
wear yours whenever you want i was like
yeah chill out they sent me a picture of
dave chappelle with
all diamond uh gold front on the bottom
dude i want one so bad what about the
mouth
yeah i know if i could do it with the
gap i would do it just the bottom with
you
does the bottom yeah well i don't you
can wear my you can try mine
my bottom teeth are pretty good i think
ass cat's looking i don't know what you
got to say about his bottom teeth
i mean his mind a little [ __ ] up i
need invisalign i needed him
no down there sorry uh nine years
recession grills
first hit the airways but american
associates this year still flashing
asap rocky no keep going down until we
see some history out there
yeah that's awesome girls are ready
egypt egypt
now wouldn't braces be a form of grills
i don't know the permanent grill uh rich
intrusion
women were the first group of people to
wear what we would now call grills
certain high status etruscan women
deliberately had
their front teeth removed in order to be
fitted with a gold band
appliance holding a replacement or
reused tooth
now it says you couldn't bite in an
apple with these
you couldn't buy an apple with these as
the gold usually held replacement teeth
in place
and it was a goldsmith who did it and
they said it was done to look nice
we all need them we i mean yeah we got
to get them
[Music]